Let's go next to, uh, let's go to Mike from
Georgia at the seven Oh six area code.
Mike from Georgia.
What's going on?
[inaudible]
Hey David, how are you doing?
Good, thanks.
Okay.
So, uh, I had a question.
So, um, we hear a lot about, um, you know,
in the debate that they asked, uh, right-wing
framed questions.
But don't we need a right-wing frame questions
if we're going to be taking on, you know,
the uh, the Republican establishment or really
just the establishment as a whole.
Yeah.
So, so you're asking a very important question.
So here's the thing, some during, during democratic
debates, the point is to best figure out who
of the democratic candidates, really it's
for two things.
Whose policies do you most agree with?
And we are also making judgments about electability.
We are imagining the candidates on the stage
debating Donald Trump.
So it seems like what you're pointing out
is at a certain point, the democratic nominee
is going to have to face Trump and is going
to have to face Republican arguments.
Therefore, isn't it logical for the moderators
to be making some of those Republican arguments
in questioning the Democrats?
Is that sort of what you're saying?
Yeah, yeah.
That's basically what I'm saying.
Here's the problem with it.
When the moderator is framing up a question
for all of the people on the stage that's
not about asking a particular candidate how
something about their policy will work.
When you frame the entire question in a way
that is a Republican slant, you're in a sense
discrediting the fact that this is even being
discussed in particular terms and that's why
it's so problematic.
If you have different Democrats up on the
stage and someone wants a public option for
health care, someone wants Medicare for all,
some someone wants a phased in Medicare, you
know you have all these, all these different
things.
You want that to be debated in a way that
is sort of fair and neutral and let the candidates
frame their positions and if they want to
bring up what it is that Donald Trump wants
to do, fine.
When the monitor moderators a priori frame,
the entire question where the logical answer,
the right position is one.
That is what Republicans are advocating for
or more to the right.
Not only is it not the point of the democratic
debates, it also is helping the more conservative
candidates up on the stage.
And so we just don't want it.
That's not the role the moderators were supposed
to have.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, that, that definitely makes sense.
Um, I always just kind of found a hypocritical
that they're supposed to come off as a neutral
force and yet they seem to go in more towards
a, uh, a Republican direction or really setting
up all these trap questions that you can't
really, you can't really wiggle your way out
of unless you attack the framing of the question.
That's another good point, which is that it
took to properly handle that you're putting
the candidates in a position where they either
have to go after the moderators for the framing,
which they should do.
And I'm glad when they do it, but that takes
time away from actually figuring out who onstage
has the best policy.
And so it's also a distraction in that way.
Oh yeah.
And, and that's kinda like my, my problem
with debate other than the fact that I don't
know how much they'll, they'll change the
course of the election.
Cause I mean, I feel like most people kinda
have an idea of who they want to vote for.
Yeah.
At this point in the game, this late in the
game, the debates will do very little to change
public support other than if someone blunders
terribly and they will then be hurt.
But it is very difficult at this point in
the game to really gain very much by doing
well in the debates because people are mostly
familiar with the candidates and with their
positions.
Yeah.
All right, well you pretty much answered my
questions, so thank you very much David.
All right, thanks Mike.
Great to hear from you.